and what other skills do you have what
other kooky jobs have you had so when
I'm not you know when it's not babies or
Gibbons or music or sales
um I've also worked in the world of
Finance which was in some way a that was
an indirect indirect tax reclaim sales
job a whole other direction and then I
was also an Arts Auctioneer on cruise
ships and that's where I learned myself
wait a minute you sold what kind of art
is being auctioned off on a cruise ship
and how bad is that art I mean that's
not a place to auction off art is a is a
cruise ship is it you wouldn't think did
you sell it in international waters
because it's been stolen that's exactly
what it is all that missing arts and all
those paintings that people are throwing
paints on at the moment that's where
they go oh those are the cruise ships
international waters I understood
no no there's amazing Arts amazing
artists on their ships and um yeah I was
an Auctioneer for two years that's where
I learned the skills the sales skills
wow that's cool Incredible you're
drinking a lot of water Josh you've had
many gulps of water while we're talking
um
about that well I'm I'm suspicious it is
true I've noticed too and it does feel
like you're sort of nervous are you
lying to us or something or what what's
the feeling you're getting I'm getting
the feeling that uh Josh is pulling some
kind of scam on us uh he's I it's a tell
when someone's drinking too much water
it's thirsty no he's gonna pitch a
timeshare yeah you are you're gonna look
at him look at him there he goes again
oh my God that's a lot of water have you
been urinating the whole time you've
been talking to us yeah there's a bucket
underneath you did say it was a one-room
thing where everything happens
thank you oh she's sitting on the toilet
as we speak uh-huh yeah it's like a jail
cell just a toilet in the middle of the
room okay well you're are you a good
Auctioneer I like to think I was decent
yeah and I had fun doing it imagine
you're selling an appearance on uh Conan
O'Brien needs a friend okay could you
auction that off right now to us we're
the buyers yeah we're the buyers good
luck pass okay
security is escorting Sona out because
she doesn't you know she's she's not
dressed appropriately
um she's wearing that's actually how a
lot of the auctions were so that's
pretty accurate so far all right so
you're the auctioneer for Conan O'Brien
an appearance on Conan O'Brien uh needs
a friend and this is you get out you
want to get top dollar for this all
right ladies and gentlemen next on the
Block we have an incredible offer a
talking appearance on Conan O'Brien
needs a friend ladies and gentlemen this
has an estimated retail price of 3 500
but we're gonna start the bidding at
just
2500.00.00
that guy's a genius I have ten thousand
going two thousand dollars Conan O'Brien
Conan O'Brien stroke in the
brown code
no no I will pay more I didn't realize
it was that the guy that worked on The
Simpsons the guy that changed the face
of late nights the guy who then reshaped
audio as we know it
000 180
000 wait sold out O'Brien we have 180 no
no not Soledad retracted retracted
the NBC broadcasters yes you wanna well
I do like Soledad O'Brien so okay there
was some confusion there anyway
um that was good you had me very excited
I was really I can tell yeah not so bad
yeah well I raised my voice and I used
profanity that usually means I'm excited
yeah yeah you're really excited a bit on
yourself
that was the most masturbatory thing
I've done since I last masturbated
um
sorry about that Josh
please
come on it's Jesus it's been a full hour
um
[Laughter]
let's change the subject